you notice anything different about the  simple is this a quiz I get it right - I  get not a poster don't want you to get  it right that means what I did worked  I'm gonna get it wrong on purpose laughs  for once in your life can you be bloody  no man normal very normal  [Music]  there's no proven its father Zeus the  lights managers why don't you just take  more Tomatoes what's wrong with you  [Music]  can you come up here should've left  daddy don't you fish we still have to  feed it flashy flashy  [Music]  there isn't a moment I won't be there  with it in a particular style today it  suits you  what would Tessa door doesn't take our  tea cozy  [Music]  so  this feeling that if I can get through  it but somehow change me I don't think  it has I don't think I want it to  [Music]  you